hey what's up guys my name is eterno
welcome back to another video
Gama coffee means I can make a video now
so today I thought I would kind of just
make a little video it's going to be a
small one kind of a midweek thing for
you guys well I just I just wanted to
talk about something that I didn't feel
would take that long that being said the
amount of videos that I started off
being like this is going to be a short
video and then it's ended up being
something that's like half an hour long
has been like I mean all of them really
but today we're just going to talk about
the way that I set up my say plus
projects these aren't necessarily going
to be the best settings for everyone
Tampa
however it is what I use it's what I've
kind of learned like grown into using
over the years and honestly every single
service loss project or like and I'm not
just talking about a single project I'm
talking about like a whole solution of
projects so every single one that I
create from now on pretty much I use
these settings so let's just let's just
jump in and take a look so we've just
opened Visual Studio we've got our start
page here nothing's I haven't opened any
kind of solution yet I'm going to create
a brand new project and solution here by
hitting file new and then project for
now I'm just going to go onto Visual C++
general and create an empty project and
then I'll just call it something like
new project now in terms of the location
I like to store the projects that I
develop under the seed directory and not
inside the user folder that way when I'm
switching computers or anything like
that it's not going to break any parks
and really it's just a lot easier to
kind of store your development project
in some kind of central directory so I
like to do something like say flash dev
and then maybe we'll call it new project
or something like that now because we've
got create directory resolution it will
actually automatically create that new
project folder so I need to write that
I'll just hit OK and we'll see what
happens
I'm sure it's taking a while okay so
once we've got this new empty project
you can see we have absolutely no files
here or anything like that if I
right-click on the actual project and
hit open folder in File Explorer you'll
see the actual directory structure the
visual studio has created for us so what
we've actually got is inside that dev
folder we've got that new project we've
got a solution file right next to there
you can see that also what
studio has done it is called our
solution the exact same as our project
so that's not necessarily something that
you want if this is just going to be a
solution with a single project in it
then maybe it is but you know if we're
making like a game or something then
it's very very rare for us to kind of
want our solution and project name to be
identical but anyway this structure is
actually not bad
we've got a folder dedicated for our for
our project we've got both a VCF profile
and a filters file I'm not going to get
too in-depth about all the different
files Visual Studio create now might be
an idea for another video but basically
the VCF approach is our project file
which is just an XML file and then we've
also got a solution file which is it's
only kind of weird format it's the text
folder and that's in a certain kind of
directory okay cool I actually like this
structure I'm not going to change it too
much but you'll notice that also what we
get here is a bunch of various folders
now these are not folders right there
are things called filters filters are
not folders if I right click on new
project here and do ad you'll see
there's no new folders new filter and if
I add a filter called journal or
something nothing is going to change on
our disk that's not the way that it
works this filters file however does
contain these kind of virtual folders
that we create so these are fantastic
such as organizing your source code
within folders that don't actually exist
on disk but they do exist in this
solution Explorer view so if I was to go
into source files for example and add a
new item source files is in a folder so
if I add an item with something called
main dot CPP once it creates the file
and everything you'll see that it's
actually just created that right here
next to my project and that's just I
just that's just that's just messy right
well look what why so what I like to do
is I like to create a folder called
source or SRC which contains all of my
source code and header files and all
that stuff kind of in that folder so
that my project files and any other
resources that I might be using in my
project are actually kind of actually
separated into folders and that's
something that the visual studio doesn't
set up for you automatically so you kind
of have to roll with it so if we go back
to visual studio we can click on our
project here and a little button will
appear here which says show all files if
we click that this view this view is
actually your directory structure that
is on your disk
on your harddrive so I right click now
and hit add you'll see the filter is
replaced with new folder and I can
actually make a folder called case I'll
see right if I alt tab back to my file
explorer look at that we've got a folder
called source
let's move this mendosa TP file into
that source directory now I can do so
using Windows Explorer which would mean
that I would have to manually update it
in Visual Studio or I can just click and
drag it like that and you can see that
on disk is actually moved it into that
directory okay so now Visual Studio is
actually behaving a little bit more like
I would like it to so this kind of show
all files button is incredibly useful
and honestly I kind of use that mostly
if we go back to our filters you can see
that main is still inside the source
files this is just a virtual
organization kind of scheme right I can
drag this to header files it doesn't
matter where this is right it could be
just in no filters which would make it
here I can just go ahead and delete all
these in fact it doesn't really matter
these this filter view is all just it's
all fake right it's all just kind of
there for you to just organize things
into groups it has no no relation to
actual directory structure on disk so if
I go back to Cheryl files mode there is
my main dot CPP file and I can do all of
my code here let's go ahead and just
write a quick hello world program just
something for us to build all right now
I'm going to compile this so I right
click on my projects build and you can
see that everything will build
successfully so we're his visual studio
put our exe file if we look at the
output you can see it's gone it's a new
project and debug a new project
Exe so debug being our currently
selector configuration if we open our
file explorer once again and we check
this out so it hasn't actually you can
see that the debug folder here which is
in the same directory as obviously X
profile however if we open it I don't
see no no new project or Exe in here
right so what's going on here we
registered in more first it looks like
it's just new project then debug so it's
not in that project folder hah
interesting let's go back to new project
and then go back again and then debug
and then oh it's in here how strange
visual studio so what's actually
happened is it put our intermediate
files into a folder called debug in our
project directory and our actual final
executable binary into a folder called
debug
in our solution directory I don't know
who makes this stuff up
it's really quite annoying I have not
actually met any professional developer
who leaves these settings everyone
changes them because they're just
honestly they are weird now it's not a
really big problem to change these and
you can create templates and stuff like
that but I'm not roasting Microsoft too
much for deciding to do this I'm just
saying that it's a little bit weird and
especially for people kind of starting
out who might not know that you can
change this you could actually be quite
difficult to find your damn executable
binary once you built it so anyway so if
we go back to the digital studio if we
right-click on our project and here
properties you'll see that on the active
under our active configuration of
platform we have an output directory and
we have an intermediate directory so
that's actually where everything is
going so you can see that everything
that we write here by the way is going
to be relative to the project file so if
I put something like intermediate here
is going to be relative to that project
file so in the same directory as our
project file which is this VTX project
file it will actually make a folder
called intermediates in this case and
put them all there ok so what I like to
change this to now first of all I like
to go to all configuration so that I'm
editing all configurations and we're not
going to make any any imma go seven
interchanges that are made here even all
platforms ok and then what I like to do
is this for my output directory I like
to put my output directory in my
solution directory slash bin slash
platform and then slash configuration
and then end that with a slash as well
ok so what it's going to do in our case
is put this into the solution directory
which is the root of this whole thing
what that means and the reason I've
actually chosen a solution directory is
because if we have multiple projects
right for example we build dll files or
something that are needed by our main
application we want them all to be in
the same folder right I don't want to
have to go into every project folder and
then deal with that I just want all of
my built binaries in one place because
that's usually the typical case you want
them all there so they're going to be in
my solution directory in a folder called
bin which types of binaries in the
appropriate platform folder so in our
case
really it will only be win32 or axe 64
and then inside a configuration so
either debug or release in our case now
this last part putting it into a
separate folder for each configuration
again not something that I do all the
time sometimes I just like to change the
target name to maybe have debug appended
to it for the debug build and
potentially release or nothing at all
depended to it for the release build if
it varies honestly based on how I how I
deal with my projects but in this case
I'm just going to put them into a
separate folder now intermediate
directories are going to be very similar
I'm going to put I'm going to I'm just
going to copy everything from the output
directory put it into the intermediate
directory the only difference is that
inside bin I'm going to make a folder
called intermediate and then put them
there by platform by configuration again
sometimes I put this intermediate folder
at the very end so there's already
inside everything but this way it's just
a little bit cleaner for you to be able
to copy save the platform that you want
and only have all the built binary is no
intermediate files so if I now see it
okay
right we can clean our project which
should get rid of a lot of the previous
files if not because it never really
does works out well I like to go into
the file explorer and just delete all of
these files that I don't care about so
all the debug directory you can see that
now I'll even delete this bin directory
you can see that now all we have is the
solution file the project we've got the
project filters and a user file which is
just basically our current Visual Studio
configuration and then in source we've
got maintance is nice and clean I'm
going to go back to visual studio and
I'm going to build alright cool so if we
go back here we go to bin we can see
we've got intermediate and then win32 so
inside intermedius legal win32 debug
that's all of our intermediate files
such as our obj files and then if we go
back you can see we've got win32 debug
and then that is our exe file and we can
run that and everything's fine
all right cool one little thing as well
you can see that we've got a double
backslash here because of course I did
forget that the solution directory
anything that has like project directory
or solution directory actually has a
backslash on it already because it's a
directory name so just go back and fix
that up so that we don't get a double
backslash if you're not sure what one of
these macros is equal to or you would
like to see what it is you can just go
under edit here
then we can expand this mappers view and
then over here we've got everything we
want to for example that solution
directory what I was talking about you
can see it's CDF new project and you can
see delve in fact and with a backslash
all right cool so that's pretty much it
that's all I just wanted to say setting
up your directory is really important
really quick tip that will just kind of
make your life easier
as far as organization goes these are
the settings that I use all the time we
might talk about more or less the
compiler settings and linking settings
and all other kind of maybe release
might optimization settings in another
video I just wanted to show you guys the
basis of how I setup every new super
sauce project that I do do you guys
enjoy this video please hit that like
button follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and and I will see you guys in
the next video goodbye
[Music]
[Music]